so Brett Kavanaugh was confirmed to the
Supreme Court I don't think that that is
breaking news at this point to be
hearing it from me a couple of days
after and the day after this completely
gongshow charade of a swearing-in at the
White House and the confirmation of
Brett Kavanaugh to the court is at the
micro-level an atrocity right you put
this erratic unhinged serial liar and
serial accused sexist altar on the court
possibly the second such sexist altar at
least really bad it's not good but in
the midst of the Cavanaugh drama there's
kind of a bigger story which is the
radicalization of the American
institutions that are part and parcel of
the idea of the United States so let's
start with Cavanaugh and the Supreme
Court the Supreme Court as an arbiter of
justice and fairness is under Trump even
more just a de facto confirmation of
corporate power and rubber-stamp
on the rights of the majority whoever
the majority happens to be over the
little guy over women over individuals
and the appointment the confirmation of
Brett Kavanaugh to that legislate a
judicial body is only going to reinforce
that so the Supreme Court as a pillar
institution of the United States has
been significantly radicalized under
Donald Trump let's talk about another
institution the Environmental Protection
Agency the Environmental Protection
Agency as a check on the sometimes bad
and destructive actions of corporations
against the environment is becoming even
more of a rubber stamp that simply
allows the decimation of our environment
to happen for the purposes of bolstering
the profits of big corporations that is
the radicalization at the base level of
the Environmental Protection Agency the
electoral systems of the 50 US states
instead of being a pillar of what makes
the United States a democracy really
it's like the main thing that makes the
United States a democracy free fearful
elections the electoral systems are
being subjugated and curtailed by the
removal of the Voting Rights Act which
has already led to attacks successful
attacks on voting rights by a more and
more right-wing Supreme Court which is
also going to influence voting law by
continued foreign and domestic attacks
on the election systems themselves and
this ranges from Russian hacking of
actual election equipment to voter
suppression tactics like reducing early
voting voter purges requirements of
voter IDs that while them they
themselves are free they require
documents that themselves are not free
corporate media as an institution
continues to become a delivery system
for polemics and profitable
scandal-mongering rather than a way for
people to just be informed about issues
that matter to them or I guess should
matter to them media in general is under
attack we've got the false claims of
fake news against media that Trump just
doesn't like or that do critical
reporting about what the administration
is doing we're seeing journalists
specifically targeted we are seeing
disdain for the institution of media and
reporting this is not going to change
anytime soon
this is a wholesale radicalization of
American institutions and if you look at
research about radicalization most of
that research is about how an individual
person becomes radicalized right
sometimes they become radicalized and
they become a terrorist as an example
what you quickly learn when you look at
radicalization research is that in order
to radicalize you have to get people to
not only reject the status quo but sort
of become indignant about about it even
if they misunderstand the status quo now
sometimes there are good reasons to
reject the status quo so as an example
our campaign finance system is
completely broken to get people to
really activate against our campaign
finance system you need people to
understand why the status quo doesn't
work but radicalization often comes for
tricking people into opposing the status
quo in ways that aren't actually rooted
in fact so here's an example right how
do you turn people against the media you
claim it's broken fake news every time
they criticize the president there are
huge problems in media we've talked
about media consolidation we've talked
about bias - sensationalism I won't give
you the full list right now but the
problems in media are not the ones that
Donald Trump claims are the problems
that he's using to successfully turn
people against the media that is how you
radicalize how do you get Republicans to
support the radicalization of the
Supreme Court by confirming a lunatic
unhinged serial accused sexist alter you
attack the status quo of all of those
claims against Cavanaugh being
democratic smears maybe even involving
the Clintons from years ago I don't even
know how you get to that conclusion but
they tried it so what's the answer is
voting enough I don't know I don't know
that's why I've been saying for a while
that really for change to happen we more
likely are going to need to go beyond
just voting I've talked about civil
disobedience I've talked about general
or industry-wide strikes
everybody has to vote and when not
voting would have one the number of
electoral votes in the 2016 presidential
election in all but like two states that
had at least 50% voting we need
everybody voting first and foremost but
is voting gonna be enough to turn back
the radicalization we're saying well
it's fighting dirty I think so voting is
step one right we have to take back the
Senate House and presidency for 2020 and
then we'll look at things like maybe
packing the court splitting up
California adding DC in Puerto Rico as
states maybe that's how we win but
that's only if and when we actually get
out and vote which most people don't do
particularly in midterms and then have
to push a bunch of stuff through so that
gets me to my question do we need to
attempt to bring elements of our economy
to a halt to show that we're serious
like is it at the point where only civil
disobedience in general strikes have
even the potential to
really change this radicalization I
don't know the answer I want to hear
from you and what I want to hear from
you about is what will it take and is
simply its is simply voting actually
enough I want to hear from you about
that